Here is your Facebook or G+ page, and of course you're smiling.
On it is your list of friends, and we already know it's either 80 or 20 friends.
In expectation it's 50 friends.
Let's pick a random one of your friends, like this one.
This person will also have a Facebook or a G+ page.
Before I raise the question how many friends this person has,
let's consider that this might be either a type A or a type B person.
Keep in mind that type A have 80 friends and type B have 20 friends.
The question I have for you is what are the chances you picked a type A friend?
This should be a number between 0 and 1.
I'm also going to ask you for the opposite.
What are the chances you picked a type B?
Please enter both numbers, and these numbers should sum up to 1.
Submit and then next.
I should warn you this is a challenging question.
If you don't get this right, don't worry.
This is the type of stuff you'll know when you've taken the class.
I just want to tease you a little bit in the beginning.